le troisième gouvernement barre souvent
les mêmes mais les structures chaude
secrétaire d'état domination imminente
il symboliseront le rajeunissement et
l'ouverture le chômage en europe
les syndicats de 18 pays inquiet ils se
mobilisent et demande un nouveau type de
croissance marée noire les vents
poussent la nappe de mazout vers les
côtes du nord
un monsieur bonsoir depuis un peu plus
d'une heure on sait maintenant de
quilles raymond barre s'est entouré pour
son troisième gouvernement vous le
verrez pas de bouleversement
spectaculaire juste un petit gonflement
des effectifs du cabinet barre il faudra
ajouter à cette liste ld socata d'état
rattaché à tel ou tel ministère liste
que nous connaîtrons peut-être demain et
puis quelques changements structure dans
les rouages du cabinet barre mais sans
plus attendre je vous laisse découvrir
ce nouveau gouvernement tel que là tout
à l'heure présenté aux journalistes le
secrétaire général de l'elysée
conformément à l'article 8 de la
constitution
monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing
président de la république a nommé comme
membre du gouvernement sur la
proposition du premier ministre garde
des sceaux ministre de la justice
alain peyrefitte ministre de la santé et
de la famille simone veil -le ministre
de l'intérieur christian bonnet ministre
des affaires étrangères louis ii guy
ringot ministre de la défense
yvon bourges ministre du travail et de
la participation
robert boulin ministre de la coopération
robert galley ministre de l'économie
rené monory ministre du budget maurice
papon ministre de l'environnement et du
cadre de vie
michel d'ornano ministre de l'éducation
christian bilhac ministre des
universités
alice saunier cité ministre de
l'agriculture pierre méhaignerie
ministre de l'industrie andré giraud
ministre des transports joël le theule
ministre du commerce et de l'artisanat
jacques barrot
ministre du commerce extérieur jean
françois deniau ministre de la jeunesse
des sports et des loisirs jean pierre
soisson ministre de la culture et de la
communication jean philippe lecat
secrétaire d'état aux postes et
télécommunications norbert se garent
secrétaire d'état aux anciens
combattants
norris plantier c'est le gouvernement
qui a été constituée s'efforce de
répondre dans sa composition aux
orientations qui avait été donnée par le
président de la république
en premier lieu la poursuite du
redressement économique de la france et
vous constaterez et l'innovation de
l'équipe ministérielle c'est à dire la
présence de deux ministres dont la haye
chargé de l'économie et dans l'autre est
chargé du budget
la tâche du ministre économie et des
finances étaient écrasantes
nous entrons dans la voie de cette
simplification dont il est si souvent
question bien entendu je tiens à le
souligner la politique économique et
financière est un aspect de la politique
globale du gouvernement et à ce titre le
premier ministre ne se désintéresse pas
de la politique économique et financière
un autre aspect sur lequel je me permets
d'attirer votre attention c'est la
réforme très importante qui intervient
en ce qui concerne les anciens
départements ministériels de
l'équipement et de l'environnement et la
qualité de la vie
la réorganisation qui est fait me paraît
correspondre aux exigences
de l'époque nous entrons dans une ère où
le qualitatif doit inspirer les
décisions qui concernent l'équipement de
ce pays
l'organisme la construction ce qui fait
que la constitution d'un grand ministère
de l'environnement et du cadre de vie
répond à cette exigence
alors quelques chiffres maintenant le
nombre des femmes ne bouge pas de et ce
sont deux jours yémen simone veil prend
encore du galon et alison i say it et
l'équipe politiques ne changent guère
lui non plus au temps du ds
qu'auparavant autant de majorité
présidentielle mais deux ou trois
pierres de plus quant au mouvement
entrées sorties et bien trois départs et
si l'arrivée de roissy
maurice papon ministre du budget député
du cher depuis 1968 monsieur pape on a
aujourd'hui 67 ans il a été pendant huit
années préfet de police à paris à
l'assemblée nationale il a été
successivement président de la
commission des finances puis rapporteur
général de cette commission
ce qui explique sa nomination
aujourd'hui au ministère du budget andré
giraud ministre de l'industrie c'est le
nouveau nom parlementaire 53 ans
polytechnicien ingénieur des mines
monsieur giraud a été successivement
directeur des carburants vice-président
des usines renault et directeur du
cabinet d'olivier guichard alors
ministre de l'éducation nationale depuis
1970 henri giraud était déléguée au
commissariat à l'énergie atomique
joël le theule ministre des transports
député de la sarthe depuis
cinquante-huit monsieur l'automne a été
ministre plusieurs fois sous la vème
république notamment aux dom tom et à
l'information
il a été par ailleurs président de la
commission de la défense nationale à
l'assemblée
âgé de 48 ans c'est un agrégé de
géographie qui devient ministre des
transports jean pierre soisson ministre
de la jeunesse des sports et des loisirs
43 ans conseiller référendaire à la cour
des comptes jean pierre soisson est un
ancien énarque plusieurs fois secrétaire
d'état depuis 1974 universités formation
professionnelle jeunesse et sports le
député maire d'auxerre avait accepté
d'abandonner le gouvernement pour le
secrétariat général du parti république
aujourd'hui c'est une promotion pour
jean pierre soisson puisqu'il bénéficie
d'un ministère à part entière
jean philippe lecat ministre de la
culture et de la communication mais ce
que le cac est lui aussi un énarque il a
42 ans il a été plusieurs fois
secrétaire d'état et ministre sous la
vème république notamment à l'économie
et à l'information depuis 1976 il était
chargé de mission à l'elysée et porte
parole du président de la république
avant d'être réélu député à beaune en
côte d'or maurice plantier secrétaire
d'état aux anciens combattants 57 ans
médecin de profession monsieur plantier
député des pyrénées atlantiques depuis
1968 nouveau secrétaire d'état aux
anciens combattants et commandeur de la
légion d'honneur rené haby bien qu'élu
au premier tour en meurthe-et-moselle
quitte le gouvernement et le ministère
de l'éducation dont il était titulaire
depuis 1974
andré rossi réunit députés à château
thierry a été successivement porte
parole du gouvernement
puis ministre du commerce extérieur dans
le dernier gouvernement fernand icare le
député des alpes-maritimes n'était entré
au gouvernement que récemment et son
passage au ministère de l'équipement
n'aura duré que sept mois par le chef de
l'état avait souhaité qu'il n'y ait pas
de cumul de fonctions importantes pour
ses ministres ainsi n'a pas été fait
appel dans le gouvernement à des maires
de grandes villes sauf le cas de robert
galley qui est maire de troyes ou bien
des présidents de conseils généraux
pas de grands changements nous l'avons
dit bref la continuité en revanche
quelques bouleversements de structure et
non des moindres puisque l'on remarque
d'abord que le ministre de l'économie et
des finances le ministère l'économie et
des fiances est coupée en deux groupes
oui alors là je ne reviendrai pas sur
les explications que monsieur bart a
donné tout à l'heure sur le perron de
l'elysée que nous venons d'entendre je
crois qu'il faut quand même souligner
que s'il y a maintenant un ministre de
l'économie qui n'est plus seulement un
ministre délégué mais un ministre à part
entière
le premier ministre garde la
responsabilité générale de la politique
économique et financière du pays et en
particulier c'est lui qui va suivre
personnellement l'évolution des
problèmes économiques financiers et
monétaires à l'échelon international
alors je poursuis la liste avec les
surprises dans les ti oui je vois
environnement et cadre de vie c'est la
métamorphose de l'ancien messin l'équipe
oui on peut parler soit de moteurs de
métamorphose ou d'éclatement ou en tout
cas de changement en profondeur là aussi
le premier ministre s'est expliqué tout
à l'air le ministère de l'équipement
avait écrit en 1966 on estime que
maintenant il a rempli son rôle que la
france est équipé mais un des soucis du
gouvernement était de mettre fin à ce
conflit qu'il y avait entre
l'environnement d'une part et puis le
développement le développement urbain en
particulier maintenant c'est le même
homme qui aura en charge la l'harmonie
souley entre ses deux fonctions
alors le même michel d'ornano qui perd
donc la culture la culture qui devient
un ministère plein avec la communique
avec la communication c'est à dire que
la la le nouveau ministre qui est
monsieur jean philippe lecat qui était
autrefois secrétaire d'état puis
ministre de l'information
or en charge à la fois la culture et
l'information et en particulier les
problèmes techniques et financiers et de
la presse il faut ajouter aussi à propos
de cet éclatement du ministère de
l'équipement que il ya la création d'un
grand ministère des transports on voi
apparaître le mot de participation à
coller celui de travail ieee l'heure ce
n'est pas la première fois il y avait
déjà eu dans
un gouvernement de monsieur chaban
delmas un secrétariat d'état à la
participation cette fois ci et c'est le
ministre du travail qui est à la fois
ministre du travail des ministres de la
participation
il faut souligner que c'est monsieur
boulin monsieur boulin qui était le
collaborateur direct de monsieur barre
sur le plan de l'économie et l'on
souligne dans l'entourage du premier
ministre qu'il connaît bien précisément
les limites jusqu'où on peut aller et
dans le domaine de la justice sociale ce
que le premier ministre avait déclaré
récemment
nous irons jusqu'aux limites des
possibilités de l'économie pour y
remédier aux bas salaires il faut
souligner aussi que monsieur boulin est
un rpr est un gaulliste shalit aurait pu
dire oui et 1 chamanistes et que
d'ailleurs un certain manque des repères
on retrouve l'effectif du cnia plusieurs
shabani se disant et le mot de
participation est un des mots clés du
gaullisme que monsieur giscard d'estaing
que monsieur bart y compris dans le
programme de bois ont repris alors comme
on touche à léquilibre justement on voit
tenir plus de radicaux du tout on voit
qu'il n'ya plus de radicaux
effectivement et en particulier notre
que monsieur rossi aurait préféré rester
parlementaire et se consacrer un travail
d'unification de la famille radicale la
deuxième pôle d'attraction pour les
commentateurs politiques aujourd'hui
l'assemblée avec le discours d'ouverture
de jacques chaban delmas qui invitait la
majorité a marché main dans la main avec
le gouvernement et avec la suite des
négociations entre partis pour les
présidences de commission
l'udf a d'abord confirmé sa proposition
de deux présidences pour l'opposition le
rpr a marqué ses réticences et dans ces
conditions les socialistes étaient
tentés de ne pas accepter une seule de
ses présidences de commission on ne pas
se désolidariser des communistes mais
revenons donc à la déclaration de
jacques chaban delmas tels que le
nouveau président de l'assemblée l'a
résumé pour la technique à daniel brands
gouvernement et majorité doivent marcher
la main dans la main le gouvernement
avec la majorité issue des urnes et la
majorité avec le gouvernement
l'expression des orientations définies
par le président de la république
ainsi sera assurée la part capitale du
fonctionnement de nos institutions
celle qui repose sur l'existence d'une
majorité parlementaire dont il ne
saurait être question de mettre en cause
l'identité aux groupes de l'opposition
de proposer des solutions fondées sur
leurs philosophies politiques et leurs
programmes a eu aussi de critiquer les
projets du gouvernement et les
propositions de la majorité afin de les
combattre
ou mieux de les amender il faut pour
cela que l'expression de ces groupes
soient non seulement libre mais
faciliter autant que faire se peut voilà
pour la politique
à ce stade du journal je voudrais
maintenant vous parler de trois faits
divers qui se sont déroulés dans un
rayon d'une centaine de kilomètres
d'abord ce qui est facile à auxerre une
histoire qui à première vue avait semblé
banals lorsque le lannic pas qu on a
découvert le cadavre d'un clochard on
pensait alors à ce qui arrive souvent en
pareil cas une bagarre de pochards et
voilà que parce que des langues se sont
déliées dans la ville on découvre qu'il
s'agit d'une sauvagerie inconsciente
d'une bande d'enfants sept au total âgés
de 9 à 13 ans qui avait fait du mendiant
un souffre douleur qui lui avait lancé
des cailloux puis des pierres de plus en
plus grosse sans commentaire deuxième de
ces faits que l'on a l'habitude de
qualifier de divers le suicide d'un
commerçant de chaumont qui faisait
l'objet d'un redressement fiscal il n'a
pas trop bien compris ce que voulait
dire la lettre très administrative du
ministère des finances
il s'est suicidé par peur du déshonneur
une équipe de reportage antenne 2 a
enquêté pour nous et nous livrera ses
conclusions demain au soir d'un baisser
de rideau symbolique des commerçants de
chaumont et puis toujours à chaumont
dans la haute-marne donc cet appel au
secours qui nous a tous mobilisés
aujourd'hui mais dont on se demande ce
soir s'il ne s'agit pas d'un canular
c'est une petite fille qui dit avoir
quatre ans
et qui a téléphoné une commerçante de la
ville et à une employée de bureau à
paris pour dire qu'elle se trouvait
seule dans son appartement depuis
dimanche que sa mère l'avait quitté et
qu'elle ne peut pas ouvrir la porte
alors sensibilisés par le drame de diane
une jeune femme ou le savez à les
laisser mourir de faim ses deux enfants
les gendarmes se sont aussitôt mis en
chasse pour essayer de retrouver
l'appartement en question tout au long
de la journée
on a cru qu'il s'agissait d'une mauvaise
plaisanterie une petite fille de 7 ans
avait été retrouvée elle s'appelle
karine et avait un ami qui s'appelait
simon de plus elle avait accès au
téléphone alors on pensait que l'on
tenait celle qui faisait courir les
gendarmes et les policiers depuis hier
seulement maintenant rien ne va plus
madame tisserand qui a reçu un appel de
cette demoiselle de 7 ans n'a pas
reconnu sa voix
la petite fille suspectée n'est pas la
bonne il faut reprendre l'enquète à 0
c'est une petite était tout à fait en
détresse et bien cette petite pleuré
pleuré entre ces ensembles où j'ai
réussi à demande lui demander son nom
elle m'a dit dont corinne corinne pour
avoir le pré le nom et elle m'a dit
simon simon mêmes ailes articulées mal
que j'arrivais en fait simon et qu'elle
était donc toute seule dans la maison de
sa maman était parti depuis le dimanche
en laissant en fermant la porte à clé et
j'ai entendu à ce moment là quelque
chose un peu un bruit dans la pièce je
lui dis tu n'es pas toute seule elle m'a
répondu c'est mon chien c'est mon chien
les gens tendaient nettement le chien le
chien qui gémissait il avait sûrement
soir j'ai pas pensé de le dire à la
gamine
et puis je voulais ouvrir la fenêtre
mais je suis trop petit je n'y arrive
pas qu elle m là vraiment la part les
dix minutes 10 minutes
c'est un crochet au téléphone j'ai dix
statues qui tue appel aux non madame ono
madame et je lui ai dit écoute je vais
aller on va les chercher je veux dire un
gendarme que jeudi pour te trouver ou
donc tuer mais clément qu'elle m'a dit
pis après une manière non par clément
elle me dit peut-être bien chaumont je
ne sais pas madame
pour l'instant je penche plutôt en
faveur du canular parce que je pense que
si la fillette avait mis la disposition
de l'appareil téléphonique
elle aurait pu renouveler ses appels et
il semble pas que cela a été fait donc
je n'écarte pas a priori la version de
la personne en danger
mais j'y crois beaucoup moins que celle
du canular ou de l'affabulation et ce
serait pas surprenant en fin de compte
que nous ils ont affaire à une bande
deux jeunes gens ou de jeune fille qui
s'amusent au téléphone la question reste
entière s'agit-il d'un jeu d'enfant ou y
at il quelque part une petite fille
abandonnée en péril la marée noire
maintenant 3 développement aujourd'hui
des manifestations à paris pour
protester contre l'insuffisance du plan
polmar le jugement dans le référé
intentée par la chaîne française à
l'union fédérale des consommateurs qui
avaient appelé au boycott de ces
produits l'ufc est condamné et puis
surtout de nouvelles inquiétudes pour
les bretons des côtes du nord est du
finistère qui avait bien commencé à
nettoyer les plages mais qui voit de
nouveaux arrivés de grosses nappes de
pétrole le vent en effet tourné depuis
quelques jours ils soufflent maintenant
du nord-est et pousse donc le mazout
vers des côtes qui n'étaient pas touchés
jusqu'à la la sphère sociale maintenant
journée européenne sur le chômage des
manifestations à rome à sarrebruck à
lille à bruxelles
et puis à paris des dirigeants syndicaux
italien allemand espagnol
réunis au siège de la cfdt pour la
première fois en effet la confédération
européenne des syndicats qui rassemble
40 millions de travailleurs a organisé
une journée de mobilisation sur l'emploi
souvenirs de l'année
et
en
un reportage de laurence graff un sur
sept journées européennes du chômage
malheureusement vous avez bien vu les
images mais il n'y avait pas de sens
alors le temps qu'on essaie de recaler
un petit peu le sens j'espère que nous
pourrons le diffuser après ce prochain
sujet c'est une véritable croisade que
renault vient de lancer aux états unis
la régie en effet signé un accord avec
un constructeur américain american
motors 2% du marché américain mais ça
représente quand même pour renault deux
usines de montage
et puis surtout 16 100 concessionnaires
laventure moderne pour un constructeur
conquérir les états unis jusqu'à présent
renault après une tentative timide en 59
avec la dauphine ci est toujours cassé
les dents aujourd'hui les accords passés
avec american motors permettent
d'envisager des objectifs plus ambitieux
14000 renault 5 ont été achetés en 77
par les américains c'est peu finalement
regard des performances réalisées par
fiat volkswagen et les japonais les
états unis représentent quand même le
premier marché mondial
tous les grands constructeurs y sont
c'est un champ d'expérience que ce soit
sur le plan de la pollution de la
sécurité et de la technologie futur il
nous semble primordial
l'avantagé immédiat pour nous c'est
l'accès à un réseau qui est
proportionnellement beaucoup plus fort
que ce que l'on peut regarder manier de
camaguey motors
c'est en fait le point de force et ça a
été traditionnellement pour un an le
point de faiblesse de renault dans son
implantation il coûte une fortune de
contre un réseau de 700 concessionnaires
aux états unis est-ce que vous n'auriez
pas pu envisager la même démarche que
volks wagen par exemple construire sur
place vos usines et fabriquer vous même
sur place
oui pour prenez aujourd'hui c'est un
problème qu'on se pose en toute logique
mais le problème ne se pose pas dans les
mêmes termes que volkswagen volkswagen
un parc très important de véhicules vend
près de 250 mille voitures par an donc à
une base beaucoup plus solide sur lequel
bâtir et investir quelques centaines de
millions de dollars
nous partons beaucoup plus modestement
nous pouvons faire une opération
beaucoup plus progressive beaucoup à
massifs donc une opération de type de
vagues n aurait pas de sens économique
pour nous aujourd'hui l'opération comme
à cannes motors qui est beaucoup plus
mesuré voulu progressive a pour nous à
la fois beaucoup moins de risque est
beaucoup plus raisonnable de l'accord
signé entre renault american motors
prévoit la distribution en france des
modèles de la firme américaine
essentiellement ceux de la filiale cheap
un pari difficile pour la régie qui
semble découvrir un peu tard l'amérique
la politique étrangère maintenant la
bombe à neutrons aux questions aux
ats-unis jimmy carter à examine sa
décision de ne pas poursuivre sa
production décision dans les jours à
venir
italie 19 jours après son enlèvement
nouvel appel pathétique de monsieur
moreau à rome je la prenais hier soir à
l'heure du journal le président de la
démocratie chrétienne a écrit à son
secrétaire général et souhaite être
échangés contre des membres des brigades
rouges emprisonné à turin le
gouvernement réaffirme son intention de
ne pas céder au chantage se posant par
ailleurs beaucoup de questions sur les
passions qui ont poussé aldo moro à
écrire cette lettre proche orient anouar
al sadate favorable un sommet arabe est
moche et bayane en roumanie on sait que
le ministre israélienne des affaires
étrangères peut nouer facilement des
contacts avec telle ou telle
personnalité arabe hors de ses
frontières
donc un loyer à la suivent sur le
terrain maintenant et bien les casques
bleus s'organise la france pourrait
porter ses effectifs à plus de mille
hommes
accra à trois kilomètres à l'ouest du
pont de casse mire point de passage
obligé du matériel lourd palestiniens
vers le sud liban ici on peut observer
la vallée du litani sur une dizaine de
kilomètres
aucun mouvement ne peut passer inaperçu
cette position est donc la première
avoir été occupée par les casques bleus
français
quarante huit heures après leur arrivée
depuis ce moment les tirs d'intimidation
n'ont jamais cessé
sans faire de victime une façon comme
une autre pour les fedayin qui occupait
auparavant ce python de montrer qu'ils
n'entendent pas se laisser contrôler par
les casques bleus
leurs arguments les forces de l'onu sont
ici pour superviser le retrait israélien
non pour mettre un frein aux activités
des palestiniens dans la région et pour
bien marquer leur mauvaise humeur ils se
plaisent à rappeler que les troupes
françaises mises à la disposition de
l'onu sont les mêmes que celles qui ont
combattu en algérie ou au tchad
allant même jusqu'à parler d'une
intervention directe de la france aux
dépens des propos dont on ne s'émeut pas
outre mesure au quartier général des
casques bleus français a dit il est vrai
que le sang froid et de rigueur dans une
région où le moindre mouvement d'humeur
peut avoir des conséquences dramatiques
on le des points essentiels de l'action
ici que je dois mener c'est de ne pas
mettre les efforts des nations unies
dans une situation intenable et qui
provoquerait plus de drames que notre
arrivée
notre arrivée ici et est essentiellement
destinée à dédramatiser une situation si
on ajoute des tensions un pays qui en a
déjà trop connu je vois pas très bien en
courant rempli notre mission du moins
l'esprit de notre mission or maintenant
dans quelques minutes coup d'envoi de
match très important pour la suite des
championnats de france de football
puisque l'on pourrait bien se retrouver
ce soir avec trois leaders ex-aequo
marseille monaco et nantes à condition
que les deux premiers gagnent contre
rouen et laval dans les faits débattu
hier battu à strasbourg 1 0
à défaut de recevoir les artistes
soviétique l'opéra de paris vite
actuellement à l'heure du new york city
ballet tu les chorégraphies de george
balanchine exécuté par le corps de
ballet de l'opéra avec en vedette
guylaine desmare ont enchanté et georges
bégoux et les amateurs les plus
difficiles c'est dire
imiter ce marais la seule étoile
françaises à qui georges balanchine a
confié tous les rôles importants du new
york city ballet depuis deux ans un
privilège que beaucoup de stars
internationales lui envient elle en
garde à la fois une technique
éblouissante et le souvenir de rapports
affectifs assez rare entre une danseuse
et chorégraphe
mais c'est alain chainey un très grand
génie que nous allions tous infiniment
je crois qu'il m'a invitée parce qu'il
me considérait comme une des siennes
dans sa campagne isme nous sommes comme
à lemont dirais-je avec un père avec
quelqu'un qui vous tient moralement
spirituellement physiquement et nous
donne un stop me now une énergie
fantastique pour répéter on a envie de
danser pour lui autant que pour le
public
il est même on s'oublie complètement
pour faire ce qu'ils demandent
tandis qu'à l'opéra de paris nous avons
un public différent un répertoire
différent
cet autre chose nous faisons les grand
ballet en trois actes il ya davantage la
possibilité des panneaux et à peut-être
sa propre personnalité
mais on danse pas dans le même état
d'amour c'est certain
mon père
e
voilà avant de refermer en musique la
dernière page de ce journal quelques
dernières nouvelles brèves mais non mr
président sadate a accepté une
invitation de se rendre le 1er mai aux
états unis
si ces engagements le lui permettent il
a ajouté le chef de l'état égyptien se
trouverait ainsi aux états unis au même
moment que le premier ministre menahem
begin qui soit là bas pour fêter le
trentième anniversaire d'israël puis une
information qui concerne la france et la
vie quotidienne des français et df
souhaite relèvement de 15% de ses tarifs
pour financer le programme nucléaire
merci le temps demain il sera brûle mais
avec de faibles pluies sur les régions
côtières de la manche sur les régions
méridionales le ciel vous le voyez sera
couvert avec des ondées orageuses
locales
ailleurs temps plus frais avec de belles
éclaircies dans l'après midi satan qui
surprend en avril et on ne reconnaît
plus très bien les saisons ainsi mis
vert arrive au printemps dans l'ariège
la neige vous voyez tombe sur les
sommets près du col de puymorens temps
difficiles pour les automobilistes mais
pour la plus grande joie des skieurs
ce journal est terminée je vous rappelle
de rendez-vous vous avez encore avec
l'actualité tout de suite à 20h30
question de temps un très beau film de
paul faire et adolphe trait sur les
prisons de femmes 24 heures à perpétuité
et puis à 22h30 avec patrick lecocq la
dernière édition du journal
bonsoir à demain